so welcome back everyone now that we
kind of understand the basics of what a
blockchain is let's see how to use it
for its first application namely
building a cryptocurrency
so just a quick review of what we saw in
the last segment um as i told you a
blockchain basically is a sequence of
transactions
so here you see you know one transaction
followed by another transaction all the
way
from the beginning of time all the way
indefinitely
and these transactions are actually
partitioned into blocks where each block
is published as a as a whole onto the
blockchain and then that publishes all
the transactions in the block onto the
blockchain the properties we said that
blockchains have is basically the
persistence property which means that
once a transaction is written to the
blockchain it can never be removed
and the consensus property which
basically says everybody everybody
agrees on the current set of
transactions that are written to the
blockchain yeah the only exception as we
said is maybe the last few transactions
uh there's still disagreement on but
that converges after a while so that
eventually everybody agrees which
transaction should be on the blockchain
in which transaction should not
so to implement the cryptocurrency using
a blockchain we understand we need to
understand an important ingredient
called a digital signature so let me
briefly explain what a digital signature
is so a digital signature is made up of
three
steps okay so the first step is
generating what's called a key pair so
there's a public key and a secret key
both of those are very short they're
only 32 bytes the public key is going to
be published to the whole world and the
secret key is going to be kept secret so
that only the person who needs to sign
messages
knows what the secret key is
okay so step number one is generate a
key pair step number two is that anyone
who has the secret key can actually sign
arbitrary messages using that secret key
and when you sign a message the result
of that is what we call a signature but
the signature itself is also just a 64
byte string it's not an actual physical
signature all it is is just a sequence
of 64 bytes that we call a signature by
the signer on the message that was just
signed
once the signature is generated anyone
who has the public key can actually
verify the signatures in particular
there's a verify algorithm that takes
the public key the message and the
signature and then the verify algorithm
either says accept or reject yeah
decides whether the signature is valid
or invalid and again the point is that
only someone who has a secret key can
sign a message that will then be
accepted as valid by this verification
algorithm okay so
uh there are lots of digital signatures
out there the most common ones that are
used in the cryptocurrency space are
called ecdsa signatures schnorr
signatures and bls signatures
and again i want to emphasize that as
long as you hold the secret key you are
the only one who can sign messages
using that secret key if someone else
tries to sign messages on your behalf
and they don't have your secret key they
can't generate a signature that will be
accepted as valid by their verification
algorithm okay so using this digital
signature
then that allows us to implement the
currency and again you can think of a
digital signature as the real world
analog where you can sign a document and
then once you've signed it anyone in the
world can verify that you are actually
the one who signed that document okay so
let's see how we use a digital signature
to implement the currency so the first
thing we need to understand
is how accounts are represented
so to be paid in bitcoins what we're
going to do is we're going to generate
as i said a public a public private
key pair for a digital signature scheme
so that i would do like on my own
machine i'll generate a public key and a
secret key
that public key is going to correspond
to what's called a bitcoin address so
what is the bitcoin address well
basically what i do is i take my public
key and i hash it so that the address
itself becomes like 32
bytes of data okay so that remember
remember what a hash function is it
allows us to take arbitrary data and
compress it into 32 bytes in this case
we're just taking the public key and
generating
a hash value from it okay good so that's
going to be our address
and in fact you can easily do this on
your own machine i kind of encourage you
this is kind of a fun thing to try on
your own go to this
address bit address dot org this is a
private this is a bitcoin um public
private key generator that runs in your
own browser okay so you go to this
address you get some javascript into
your browser
you hit uh run and it will go ahead and
generate uh
the secret key for you and the public
key okay so the secret key you're gonna
keep for yourself this is something that
you can print out and keep on a piece of
paper for your for your own and then
this is the public key that you can give
to the rest of the world so that they
can send you funds to that address okay
so
once you encode uh the hash of the
public key as printable characters
basically sort of restricted basics
before you end up with a 34 byte address
you can tell anyone in the world that
this is your address they can then send
you funds and the only way you can spend
those funds is by signing a transaction
that authorizes the expenditure of funds
from that address and to sign those
those
authorizations you need to have the
secret key which is uh kind of also
represented over here and the
interesting thing is you can store these
as qr codes these are the qr codes um so
you can easily put it in front of a
camera and a computer can actually read
those character strings in you don't
have to actually type in these character
strings when you want to use them so
literally you go to this address you
generate the public and private key pair
you keep the private key you know to
yourself to yourself in your safe or
elsewhere
the public key you tell the whole world
and now they can start sending funds to
you
okay good and as i said as we said
before the secret keys in fact needed to
spend funds from uh the address that you
just created so that's it that's all a
bitcoin address is it's trivial to
create uh addresses that people can send
you funds to